aussi grande que toi
est-ce que vous avez trouvé le plus
difficile
ne pas voir la famille
de te sentir coupable par rapport à ça
quand on voit Dominique Anglade avec sa
famille on comprend où elle puisse
s'efforce la chef est nerveuse sondeur
et analyse prédisent la pire débarque
dans l'histoire du Parti libéral du
Québec chaque campagne le jour où ça
commence à avoir les chiffres sur le
stressant
la prochaine fois on devrait faire ça
ensemble
après le dîner la visite de bureau du
crétin s'impose parce que les nouvelles
sur la sortie du vote sont inquiétantes
merci byeuse machine libérale qui a
pratiquement inventé la recette d'une
élection gagnante n'est pas au
rendez-vous
même dans la circonscription de la chef
combien de
transports depuis presque 30 ans lundi
elle n'avait que 15 transports
d'électeurs à coordonnés à une autre
époque les bénévoles en faisaient plus
que ça en une seule heure et puis
répondre les gens on les rappelle la
veille confirmer le tout son pôle Nord
c'est tout a changé avec la pandémie
de bénévoles il faut continuer à bâtir
continuer à 1000 changements au sein de
notre formation politique c'est sûr on
s'est Henri single n'est pas collé moi
je te dis c'était le 124e sur 125
compter la dernière fois
comparer électorale est un supplice pour
la chef libéral qui préfère regarder la
télé sans le son pour ne pas entendre
les commentaires Dominique Anglade sait
qu'elle a du mal à faire entendre ses
idées je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont spolié c'est l'électrices
n'a pas voté pour la libérale parce
qu'elle est souverainiste et juges que
le racisme a joué un rôle dans cette
campagne
intéressante que des idées et qui a
peut-être un peu de la difficulté à le
faire passer puis encore du sexisme
malheureusement et je pense que ça
couleur de peau lui uni parce que vous
fait dire ça peut-être les observations
que j'ai entendu même si on est en 2022
qu'est-ce qu'on vous a dit
sur une boîte Dominique Anglade
d'origine haïtienne était la seule femme
et la première personne noire a aspiré
diriger le Québec il n'en a pas été
question durant la campagne pourquoi
c'est pour moi de répondre à cette
question là
je sais pas est-ce que est-ce que les
gens ont peur d'aborder le sujet donc
est-ce que c'était une handicap d'être
une femme noire dans cette campagne moi
j'aime pas cette termes-là c'est pas
l'état c'est pas le temps
c'est un défi c'est un défi
supplémentaire c'est sûr être une femme
dans un milieu d'homme est une femme
morte dans un milieu d'homme la majorité
blanche c'est un défi supplémentaire il
y a pas de doute allô François
félicitations pour ta victoire
ce qui attend la politicienne c'est de
rebâtir des ponts avec les francophones
à l'exception de Pontiac en Outaouais
qui libérons non plus que député dans
les régions et leurs bases militante
semble s'être volatilisés il faut
laisser aussi le temps au temps il y a
quelques éléments de ça qui est vrai là
dedans
mais elle est partie libérale aderas une
profonde c'est un parti qui est toujours
été de son temps quand c'était le temps
de donner le droit de vote aux femmes on
l'a fait quand c'était le temps de
parler de l'assurance maladie on l'a
fait quand c'était le temps de de parler
d'hydroélectricité c'est toujours de son
temps quand c'est le temps de parler de
elle tout changement climatique on le
fait
finalement Dominique Anglade a défié les
pronostics le message ce soir il est
assez clair les Québécois demandent au
Parti libéral du Québec nous demande
d'être l'opposition officielle à Québec
[Applaudissements]